à
[Musique]
ça
vous écoutez la première idée 18h16
culture première jean-paul milad bonsoir
anniversaire amérique latine au
programme de votre culture première et
musique d'abord avec elias artistes
comorienne de retour chez nous et en
tournée jusqu'au 22 juin pour une série
de concerts il a participé au yo-yo ma
le marché des musiques de l'océan indien
qui a pris fin ce soir on file dans le
sud avec des 30 ans de la médiathèque un
invité d'honneur l'écrivain olivier
rolin j'en ai dit et spécialiste de la
russie des précisions avec fabienne
lorette l'amérique latine à l'honneur à
stella matutina avec la quatrième
édition de festi gatineau gastronomie
atelier invités d'ici et d'ailleurs de
la danse aussi avec tous les styles
connus et moins connus
le spécialiste ce soir s'appelle nicolas
greiner la réalisation sonore est
assurée par gérard constantin
l'illustration musicale est assurée par
elias l'esc achats et georgie berne
cette émission est à suivre sur le site
de la première culture première de nous
retrouvons comme tous les jeudis soirs
avec gabe on s'organise tga la féministe
qui dans le studio et qui aime le
festival sakifo là ça donne quoi comme
chronique en effet si on est féministe
et bien ça donne une chronique très
tonique
alors ce soir je vous ai concocté une
spéciale artiste féminine à ne surtout
pas manquer au sakifo mes coups de coeur
sont des chanteuses d'afrique du sud du
nigeria ou du sri lanka mais elles
vivent désormais en europe ou aux états
unis
du coup il faut une musique très
métissée et entraînante voir sacrément
endiablé voici donc mon top 3 des
chanteuses incontournable du sakifo
numéro 3 i lya amende syrie basé à
l'horme ans thierry ban et c'est une
petite brindille né à soweto en plein
apartheid
a priori ça commence mal et pourtant la
résilience entre les dents monde 6 et 8
elle hésite entre la danse la mode et le
chant du coup elle choisit les trois et
ça se voit dans ces cancers elle est au
sakifo avec le producteur octobre alors
attendez vous à de la house music c'est
à dire un tempo relativement rapide et
un son électronique
irrésistible avec nancy on se rappelle
que oui l'afrique a une histoire c'est
évident mais aussi une capacité à
innover médicalement
en mélangeant son futuriste chorégraphie
de dengue et excentricités à la lady
gaga vous écouter vous tomber à la
renverse vous relever et vous dansez
mentir iban essais vendredi à 23h30 ou
médaille de bronze pour une chanteuse à
l'univers radicalement différent ses
aïeux alors on la connaît pour son down
on my knees son dernier tube paname est
un vrai rayon de soleil aussi alors ayo
c'est une voie mais pleine de grâce au
carrefour du folk et de la soul
elle apporte une note de mélancolie
d'amour et de douceur dans ce festival
ça ne fait pas de mal c'est samedi à 21h
membres du roulement de tambour babel ma
médaille d'or ma couronne de lauriers à
moi elle est pour la rappeuse mia c'est
sa first time à la réunion j'ai
l'impression qu'à yam quand il chante et
je danse le mia annoncé sans le savoir
sa venue si vous voulez comprendre ce
que donne le croisement entre un
revolver et une princesse indienne
allez la voir mia 43 ans semble n'en
avoir que la moitié comme quoi le rap ça
conserve
on la connaît pour paper planes qu'on
entendait dans le film slumdog
millionaire
sa voix n'est pas très puissant en
concert ce qui me déçoit parfois mais si
elle s'en donne la peine
elle fera un hip hop qui décoiffe samedi
minuit à la poudrière
le lieu est parfait pour qu'elle y
mettent le feu
reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter un bon
festival fiant aux auditeurs en
attendant ma chronique de jeudi prochain
culture première
[Musique]
nana
brian déjà passé tout vendu toute la
nuit dans le gymnase à anoumabo
pour la seconde
[Musique]
attack of the show must go do you want
me rendre au boulot
[Musique]
il nous tarde à blood blues culture
première alors quand vous êtes déjà 6
alors comment s'appelle la chance qu'on
nous avait interprété s'appelle tarab
blues d'accord ok alors j'allais mais si
mon papier qui vous accompagne en fait
en fin de compte vous êtes venu tout
seul et je suis plusieurs dans ma tête
d'accord ok on va vous appeler vichnou
c'est ça alors vous de votre vrai nom il
y as benzema vous êtes né en grande
comore 78 vous avez vraiment commencer
votre casier avec ma loge avant c'était
pas lèche mais là après c'était mal a
lâché et de malaise que nous avons fait
découvrir ici nous à la réunion et à rfo
en tant que vous êtes et choristes et
percussionniste mais vous aimez la
guitare et en six ans vous avez appris
cet instrument ça c'est pas l'âge de 6
ans dont canon en six ans j'ai dit ah
oui oui ça allait très vite j'avais
j'avais 20 ans j'en ai 30 nov
aujourd'hui j'avais 20 ans et j'ai
craqué sur l'instrument et j'y croyais
pas mais après j'étais pas parti pour
faire la musique non plus
professionnellement comme moi mais comme
quoi la charge de travail quand même
mois en 2008 vous sortez votre premier
album qui s'appelle marahaba marhaba
pourquoi pour qui mme à rabat pour mes
parents c'est vrai que aux comores est
surtout en fait dans ma famille on n'est
pas très expressif
on sait pas des bijouteries les matins
on se dit pas je t'aime serait pas de
concept n'est pas européen sur
c'est par la culture se voit là et
je considère que j'ai beaucoup de chance
d'avoir des parents la traversée des
chemins des chemins quel que soit le
chemin qu'on a pris et c'est une façon
de les remercier et je sais qu'ils se
sont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup investi
pour que je fasse des études il avait
commencé des études de droit que j'ai
arrêté
pour faire la musique donc j'ai pris
beaucoup de risques aussi investi peau
sur moi c'était aussi une façon pour
leur dire merci et je vais pas vous
décevoir bien alors sans cet album donc
c'est le premier il y en a eu d'autres
entre temps après en 2011 j'ai sorti un
album en collectif qui s'appelle 100
dates 2 qui avait mikidache toro chamoux
au boss et zain aux nîmois 2011
on sait à peu près à l'époque au boss
commencé à perth exact à mayotte et
gâteaux bosse à un très bon pote qui a
eu le prix musique aussi indiens aussi
voilà alors pourquoi il dit aussi parce
que quand on les voit de dos les
syndicats ont été créés vous avez été le
premier gagnant non non c'était pas vous
c'est clair c'était pas ce prix là
c'était de laisser j'ai confondu avec
prix de l'ancien niveau de l'os yann est
la première édition où j'étais lauréat
du la première édition de la première
édition que ça vous a fait ça fait
toujours plaisir même quand on passe
dehors et qu'on a un pêcheur qui dit ah
j'adore votre musique ça fait toujours
plaisir n'en parlons pas si ce sont des
professionnels
alors justement prendre professionnel
hier soir vous étiez au yo-yo ma
prestation
oui ça s'est passé ou au bicycle j'ai
pas mangé des bichiques mais il ya du
cari poulet très dit être d'accord
alors comment ça s'est passé cette
prestation il y avait pleinement des
virements de lin de profession il y
avait plein de professionnels et il ya
eu des très bons retours ont pas trop en
parler là oui voila voila mais
normalement il ya des choses qui vont se
passer dès la fin de cette année
d'accord ok mais pas plutôt dire
septembre route non tom novembre
nous sommes 200 bon alors vous vous êtes
vous êtes toujours que vous invitez
toujours maillot tout vous n'habitez la
france j'ai même été la france aussi non
j'aime bien moi je dis la réunion et la
france mais alors vous habitez maillot
tout la france maintenant je suis en
métropole
c'est à dire mis fin 2014 d'accord ok
donc hélas et de là vous rayonnez vous
allez à droite et à gauche vous de vous
tourner oui oui tout à fait tout à fait
de la basse et encore on dit c'est
encore plus facile mais c'est pas vrai
non plus pourquoi il est le frein de
l'avion voilà il ya c'est plus facile
dans ce sens là ça peut coûter moins
cher de partie peut-être de là bas mais
pas pour venir ici aussi pour aller plus
en europe et ailleurs
et voilà on trace un chemin labatut
alors vous avez des nouveaux projets
dits temps c'est ce que j'ai vu marquer
donc sur le papier que j'ai reçu alors
c'est quoi ces projets il ya deux
projets c'est cela oui déjà là j'ai
présenté un projet biomasse est un
projet solo cela dit je joue avec ma
guitare j'ai notre instrument s'appelle
l'omr la gg une bouteille de bière sur
scène avec fabien vide greniers pour que
je lui dis j'utilise comme comme
instrument de musique d'accord et voilà
j'ai plein de petites choses et des
pédalos si pour l'heure on suit on suit
notre temps aussi
et puis voilà et dès demain je commence
une tournée on a dit dette avec un
projet trio basse batterie avec qui on a
travaillé des années à mayotte
et là on se retrouve avec jimmy qui
vient de madagascar exprès il a revu
hier soir et adib qui est un belge
marocain qui habitent là je penses tu
des questions parce que j'avais posé la
question il répond tout de suite il me
devant parce que j'avais reçues
ok des questions j'en ai jamais ces
questions avant monsieur oui la gale qui
vous pose une question et pour ceux qui
ne vous connaissais pas comme moi même
si voilà c'est fait maintenant comment
définissez-vous la musique que vous
faites
ah ah ah alors la musique entre
guillemets ma musique je l'appelle le
zinc aux mains alors aux comores on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup on a une
richesse de musique traditionnelle chez
koba voilà michel gonelle tora où j'ai
fait de l'oeil de ton rap blues parce
que on danse aussi comme voilà on a des
torts à 20 h et demain on a deux
billards madame côte chaude y en a
tellement qu'on connait même moi je les
connais pas tous et forcément on va
puiser là dedans en tout cas moi c'est
mon travail j'ai plus de dents et je
mélange avec tout ce que j'aurais reçu
de l'occident est partout et j'ai
remarqué qu'à chaque fois qu'on me poser
des questions on dit tous ceux qui sont
dans ce format là on sait pas quoi dire
on dirait ma musique métissée deux ponts
fait ombre une heure après on explique
ce qu'on fait la fête il ya un artiste
que j'adore beaucoup c'est peut-être
back aux mahorais et que c'est lui qui a
eu cette idée du 2 en commun et qu'il a
essayé de fédérer tout le monde là
dedans
et moi quand je suis arrivé j'ai j'ai
entendu ça j'ai deux mais c'est génial
et ça me correspond vraiment d'un coup
j'ai pris deux drapeaux avec lui on y va
j'avais parlé du coffret bas qu il va
encore devancé qui est bas qu à leur bac
au cil montant et se voit là c'est un
artiste on va dire comoriens de mayotte
et on va beaucoup de comoriens de
mayotte amadio temps oui parce qu'il
faut toujours précisé comoriens de
mayotte voilà aussi et
pour moi pour moi c'est un peintre de la
musique sa manière d'écrire moi je vois
toujours des images quand j'écoute ce
qu'il a une façon d'écrire c'est très
poétique et musicalement voilà n'en
parlons pas donc pour moi c'est ça à m
un maître vous avez été comprendre à la
réunion je vais retrouver mon à wau à
votre retour au chameau ces mots noir
qui m'a déposé tout à l'heure des ragots
il allait jouer à counter tout à l'heure
et ses monarques qui m'a déposé oui j'ai
vu le taureau chamoux j'ai vu voilà que
vous avez fait la teuf ça se voit sur
facebook 1 j'ai poursuivi dame attend
c'est vraiment que c'est facebook qui
vous regarde tout le temps bon alors
donc d'aider des tours des tournées
alors j'avais pourtant là je retrouvais
mon papy en fait à la réunion vous avez
une deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit
vous êtes là du 1er au 22 et vous
commencez donc demain à l'étoile du sud
et vous terminez par le toit toujours
dans le sud le 22 22 6 avec des dates
sur saint denis vous êtes 15,6 au
cathédrale vous êtes déjà les noms dont
vous allez voir c'est un lieu bras avec
assez bon mais venez il ya six tonnes
keaton vous avez encore regagne le
bicycle le 16 le 16 et vous avez enduré
parce que hier je mangeais pas manger du
be chic et djediat cas des jeux revient
cette fois-ci faut refaire et après ça
vous partez en malaisie après ça je pars
malizé avec un autre projet parce qu'on
a parlé de projet tout à l'heure j'ai un
projet monté aux comores s'appelle ellis
ou maëly eliassou soubie mamadi ces deux
instrumentistes des virtuoses à son
traditionnel gabouty et jean zay et moi
tu sais la guitare aux pédales et
le kayamb on met des percussions aussi
un projet depuis 2002 qui travaille avec
percy tank de la réunion pardon de
maurice voilà on a fait deux béquilles
ce temps l'allemagne
donc on essaie de vendre aussi ce côté
traditionnel c'est vraiment traditionnel
endroit où vous allez de fait seulement
des estivales 3,6 me semble c'est
quelque chose d d'écologie qui me sont
quelque part c'est une île j'ai passé à
côté de bornéo états unis de la géorgie
et de non jeu magra non c'est pas ça non
je dois sera possible
bref c'est pas grave
et vous restez donc qu'il ya dedans les
15 et 16 juillet c'est toi la vallée
après vous rentrer au bercail après
juste avant ça je joue dans la grotte de
lascaux pour faire un petit concert puis
film et intimiste très wii est pas prêt
je pars en malaisie après je reviens je
fais le festival
ville vit les musiques du monde apparaît
quand est-ce que vous avez le temps de
vous occuper de votre prochain cd c'est
déjà ôté déjà enregistré en rentrant je
vais travailler il faut travailler un
peu quand même
oui bien sûr donner de l'argent et vivre
il faut travailler déjà gagner de
l'argent c'est pas garantie d'accor
alors donc quand donc qui sort quand
alors on espère de sortir à la rentrée
or candidats rentrée scolaire octobre
pressé de sortir avant le festival des
villes et musiques du monde à paris pour
essayer de rebondir sur sa puis
peut-être la suite de deux lits au mas
est simple comment cet album je ne sais
pas en fait l'idée c'est que moi j'ai
une idée que je vais pas donner mais je
vais faire écouter à des gens qui ne
comprennent pas et qui y auront que les
titres et je vais voir ce que eux quand
ils vont réagir un combat des idées
l'équipe marc à bat yam arabe a beaucoup
nagl
[Musique]
à
on va
là
[Musique]
en saut de l'année
18h35 vous écoutez culture première
bonsoir fabienne redt japonais vous êtes
la directrice adjointe de la médiathèque
de saint-pierre pour 730 vous avez
concocté un programme qui tourne autour
de la personnalité d'olivier rolin
écrivain journaliste et grand
spécialiste de la russie pourquoi lui
pourquoi lui donc d'abord je vais
expliquer pourquoi la russie
parce qu'en fait on on a décidé de
mettre l'anniversaire sous le signe de
la culture russe juste pour un clin
d'oeil pour en un clin d'oeil vers le
salon du livre de paris qui accueille
chaque année un pays invité d'honneur
et cette année c'est la russie d'accord
il avait l'habitude de le faire pour les
autres pays donc on a profité de
l'occasion alors olivier rolin donc qui
est un spécialiste de la russie
oui un spécialiste de la russie il a
donc il est allé en russie en 1981 et
depuis il a fait 25 voyage qu'il a
trouvé une passion pour la russie et il
a écrit beaucoup 12 ouvrages en rapport
avec ce pays notamment alors en russie
en 1987 sibérie en 2011
le météorologue en 2014
baykal amour en 2016 et le dernier livre
avec vincent perez au comédien c'est un
livre de photographies en 2010 est un
récit de voyage ou les photographies
sont de vincent perez et les
commentaires de monsieur rôle je vous
pose une colle de cale de textes 4 vous
avez lu ou 55
alors j'ai lu le météorologue j'ai lu en
russie et il est lui aussi le voyage
ressac hommes ont sauvé comme ça des
gens qui viennent de l'extérieur des
invités d'honneur comme comme cela est
ce que vous êtes
vous sentez obligé de rentrer dans leur
littérature de connaître un peu plus
forcément oui tous bibliothèque
oui non et c'est oui bien sûr on peut
pas tout lire
évidemment mais ceux qui le reçoivent
oui alors 30 ans en 30 ans qu'est ce qui
s'est passé dans cette médiathèque parce
que ça 30 ans a fait beaucoup peut-être
mais ça passe très vite aussi en même
temps votre entente wassa ya pas
longtemps quoi en 1988 donc ok la
médiathèque l'historique pièce a été
inaugurée par françois mitterrand
c'était la première médiathèque de lille
la première fois médiathèque au sens
large du terme avec la musique
le levain les films vhs à l'époque et
l'a mérité à gauche et la mairie était
accroché et voilà donc 1988 la première
médiathèque on a eu on s'est tendu on a
quatre bibliothèque annexe la première
en 1989
condé fin à mon verre on a à basse-terre
compte des concessions on a un petit
réseau de bibliothèques terre sainte est
la dernière en date qui est en
construction à grosbois et oui on a
évolué on prête aussi maintenant pendant
qu'on avait les vhs à l'époque
maintenant me voilà le streaming
maintenant donc ce rapport est là c'est
un peu plus compliqué pour la musique
pareil et puis maintenant on ne prête
aussi des livres numériques dans le
comble alors justement on va vivre
numérique dont vous vous êtes à la page
mais la musique puisque de moins en
moins de céder quand vous allez faire
dans quelques années lorsque tout le
monde sera sur les plateformes apple etc
etc
amazon et où quand vous allez faire don
va proposer des abonnements
désabonnement ligne ou des abonnés des
écoutes sur place et peut-être que l'une
de nos missions vont changer ce sera
peut-être plus de faire fin de
l'émission
ils vont changer ça ne sera plus de 2 de
collecter de la chaussée voilà mais
surtout de mettre en valeur peut-être la
lite la musique de l'océan indien où les
faveurs de médiation culturelle ce n'est
pas encore le cas pour la musique de
l'ossétie mais on va peut-être 20 sur
les quatre opus l'accent mal à vous êtes
prêt l'impression que c'est un petit
toit les trois là en vivent là vous
savez lorsque vous avez peur socrates à
saint-pierre grandi c'est bien grandi
mais c'est pour ça qu'on aura une
nouvelle bibliothèque un grand bain donc
on s'étend sur le quartier sur le
quartier sur le territoire oui mais la
vie aussi gras de plus en plus peut-être
de monde quand même de gens parce que
van der garde et saint denis son budget
oblige et d'agrandir la biotech faire
réaménager la bibliothèque francs parce
que vous serez obligés de faire la même
chose
women's toute façon oui on n'y échappera
pas alors aujourd'hui vous avez combien
de livres l'intérieur alors on a 80
mille documents alors c'est un peu je
suis un peu choqué parce qu'aujourd'hui
- jeudi comme beaucoup de monde
et quand par un congé lui au bout d'un
certain nombre d'années je me dis bah
tiens je vais faire cadeau de mes livres
à la bibliothèque et bien on refuse on
refuse on les met où oui d'accord si
vous êtes 4 savait pas si on les a après
on a faim nous à saint pierre ont un âge
pour pas pour vous bien sûr on a un
fonds patrimonial important donc après
la mission première c'est pas un mini
une mission de conservation on à la
bibliothèque départementale qui à cette
mission et c'est vrai que pour mettre en
valeur les documents si tout est comme
la bibliothèque à l'ancienne les gens ne
se retrouvent plus donc on est obligé de
faire du marketing la biotech évolué on
est obligé de faire comme dans les
rayonnages des commerces mettre en
valeur afin dé fascine mais il nous faut
de l'espace et vous mettez aussi
promotion ali oui mais des coups
terribles méfiante et ça marche
oui ça non qu'est ce que quelqu'un qui
fréquentent plus le plus là les
personnes allez on va dire à un peu
âgées les
les jeunes est ce que ce sont toujours
des gens qui ont plutôt 40 45 50 ans oui
bien sûr on a beaucoup de retraités les
autres pays travaillent donc forcément
ils sont pas ils ont pas le temps avec
la vie de famille et et tout ça mais on
a aussi les adolescents maintenant qu'il
vienne quand même un à la médiathèque on
a un club manga on voit débarquer 50
adolescents le samedi après midi
donc ils viennent mais peut-être plus
pour la même la plus recherchée la même
chose oui mais devenu aussi voilà elle
pas lieu de vie mais un lieu de
socialisation
d'abord oui bon fallait donc les mangas
mais on a tous les publics on a un club
de bébés lecteurs on a les parents qui
viennent avec les enfants des animations
à l'intérieur de la bibliothèque
oui vous avez des attaques par oui oui
comme quoi alors on alla club de bébés
lecteurs dont club c'est un grand mot
mais on se raconte des histoires bébé on
a un club de lecture pour les bons on va
dire pour les plus âgés on a un club de
lecture pour les ados qu'à l'animation
fait des spectacles on met en valeur le
théâtre ouais on ya des jeunes regardent
encore vendent encore sonné oui mais
voilà c'est le théâtre moderne
adacore voilà vous êtes des classiques
réadapter revisité alors il y a plein de
choses donc à venir dans cette
médiathèque donc on les cinq et sept
jeunes donc olivier rolin le 6 juin vous
faites là fait la malle grosse teuf
voilà ce que vous faites
alors on commence par un réchauffé à
7h30 tradition tradition réunionnaise
mais si tu veux oui fata din va pleuvoir
des clients quand même d'accord donc
appelé justement on a des animations en
direction des 0 6 ans donc une séance de
contes une séance de bébés lecteurs
on a aussi un spectacle pour enfants la
femme de monsieur irene et puis on
l'après-midi ce sera plus pour les
adultes donc là le la dgi la projection
du film d'olivier rolin parce qu'il est
aussi réalisateur solovki les îles la
bibliothèque disparu pardon on aura de
la lecture théâtralisée des grands
auteurs russes par la compagnie culture
pays et puis après on finit en ambiance
créole avec drive voilà on a pour tous
les publics
[Musique]
qui chante seul le 9 juin il est
toujours là monsieur on voit là le 9
passes et la rencontre avec le grand
public dans la cua de la médiathèque
sous les banians en plein air
vous avez des gueules bien sûr se faire
dédicacer des livres
oui d'un grand moment hier par exemple
on a reçu quelques uns oui c'était prévu
c'était banon s'était pas un hasard on
travaille en partenariat avec le sakifo
et depuis quelques années fans depuis
quelques années depuis deux ans et c'est
vrai que bon c'est elle une opportunité
que monsieur faille qui disent voilà qui
viennent aussi il a écrit un livre qui
était tout petit et réalisé dans le jury
et est donc est ce qu il a chanté
non il n'a pas chanté il était venu
vraiment pour autant qu écrit en tant
qu'écrivain d'accord mais il était très
bien et si tu es une rencontre jeu
magnifique mais ça sera pareil pour eux
la il avait du monde
oui on était à 120 personnes alors c'est
très bien le 9 juin donc brolin a dit
cela à 19 heures il devrait donc une
séance de dédicaces une rencontre animée
par azzedine est de bon goût une
rencontre littéraire où elle va lui
poser des questions l'interviewer est
suivie d'une séance de dédicaces en
partenariat avec la librairie autrement
alors on rappelle donc les dots le grand
bain sans grandes dates de cicine avion
le 5 et 7 juin c'est pour les scolaires
dans les scolaires de simple que ça le
tampon dont non on va recevoir une
classe du collège saint-charles mardi
matin aux données dans la hotte et une
classe du lycée ambroise vollard jeudi
matin d'accord ok les autres non parce
que c'est ce que l'on n'a pas il faut
qu'on fasse des choix ils viendront à la
grande rencontre du samedi soir
merci madame nora étant donné la peur
d'être venus d'aussi loin puisque vous
venez quand même de saint-pierre deux
heures de route avec un peu moins de
robes et enfin merci d'être venu nous
parler donc des 30 ans de la médiathèque
et celle voulant que ça se passe bien
que vous ayez beaucoup de monde que pour
don part de sega déjà
cet invité ses collègues
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci culture première
festi latino 4ème édition avec vous
nicolas greiner vous êtes en vous en
êtes l'organisateur bonsoir bonsoir
derrière ce festi dati dont il ya une
association qui s'appelle souffle et
rythmes une journée donc dédié à
l'amérique latine le 9 juin on y trouve
de tout des gens d'ici et d'ailleurs des
musiques d'ici et d'ailleurs de la
gastronomie et pas d'alcool vous êtes
original que les autres en soi font du
fric grâce à un centre et vous dites
vous n'y êtes nos wii c'est inédit un
petit peu ça fait quatre ans que fait la
troisième édition à des partitions
france mais pourquoi pas d'alcool alors
c'est qu'il ya toute une histoire mais
c'est vrai que il ya une éthique
derrière tout ça le festi latino bon
c'est vrai que c'est un voyage dans
toute l'amérique latine avec toute la
richesse la diversité culturelle
musicale et puis de la danse de tous ces
pays
et puis en fait le l'idée d'organiser un
festival on va dire un événement festif
sur le thème la fiesta sent l'alcool
c'est à l'origine lié à mon expérience
professionnelle en tant qu'éducateur
sportif en milieu d'addictologie
j'ai vu défiler tellement de personnes
qui essayaient de de travailler sur
l'abstinence
donc il était en cure en sevrage mon
post cure et qui ce qui témoignait de
leurs difficultés
effectivement à travailler là dessus en
dehors du centre de soins faire que dès
que dès qu'on sort de la clinique ou du
service d'addictologie lie à des
événements il ya des soirées
présentation qu'ils sont et c'est très
difficile
alors dans ces cas là la réponse c'est
soit de consommer de retomber dans une
conduites addictives
la solution c'est aussi de s'isoler de
se dire moi je sors pas je reste à la
maison et je m'exclus finalement
socialement et voilà insidieusement
c'est l'exclusion qui se met en place
quoi et je me suis dit moi j'ai
travaillé là dedans j'organise le
musicien
de musique latino brésilienne
afro-cubaine etc j'ai envie d'organiser
ça et je me suis dit mais il faut penser
aussi à toutes ces personnes qui que
j'ai envie d'inclure quoi donc
effectivement j'ai à toutes ces
personnes qui ne boivent pas d'accord
parce qu'un acquis notamment voilà c'est
ça et puis l'idée c'est de considérer
quand on peut tout à fait passer d'une
soirée de 18h à 23h et s'amuser faire
quelque chose de très festif sens
d'avoir recours à ces avoir recours à ça
et on s'aperçoit que ça fonctionne et
que et que justement moi j'ai
l'impression qu'ils aiment vraiment une
une émulation une dynamique qui se crée
il ya du monde beaucoup de monde et ils
vous disent pas y a pas d'alcool je ne
sais pas est ce que vous entendez ce
genre de réflexion alors c'est
intéressant ce que ce que vous dites
parce que on m'a dissuadé mois les
premières années on m'a dit bon tu
organises ça mais l'amérique latine
c'est la cachaça brésilien c'est la
tequila mexicaine
ce sont les différentes bières tout le
monde me disait mais tu fuck un succès
ça va pas marcher ton truc et c'est pas
grave je tiens à conserver cette éthique
là et finalement mais il se trouve que
ça marche que ça alors en fait on se
défonce à la musique latine quoi la
musique latine à l'ambiance à tout et
puis bon je propose aussi des
alternatives quoi il ya des boissons
sans alcool qui sont savoureuses qui
sont des cocktails de jus de fruits il y
aura une sangria sans alcool qui
existent et qui sera sur le site
et puis et puis l'aspect l'on va dire le
versant préventif il existe aussi
puisqu'il y aura des professionnels de
l'addictologie qui sont sur place à
l'instant dit voilà alors vous avez donc
un village où en quelque sorte que ses
récents records qu'on y trouve alors en
dehors de ce sens en dehors de la
musique ou non en dehors de ce que vous
gardez là en dehors des stands
spécialisés ça disait prédictions il y
aura des gastronomies alors un stand qui
s'appelle torti mec ce don qui vient du
mexique avec six cas c'est ça qui vivent
ici
voilà ça c'est intéressant parce qu'il
ya deux communautés latino alors
si ken chilienne brésilienne colombienne
paraguayenne enfin il ya toute une
konyaspor à qu'on connaît peu un
argentin ici chez nous avant oui j'ai
entendu parler mais d'où l'idée
justement du festi latino fin mai mais
c'est vrai que le festi latinos et la
promotion de toutes ces musiques et
aussi la réunion de toute cette
communauté qui existe qui vit ici
alors il ya des artistes parmi parmi eux
et qu'ils jouent dans des groupes
composés de créole de latinos de
métropolitains essais et c'est aussi ce
festival c'est je voulais vraiment
parler parce que c'est vrai que le thème
c'est l'amérique latine mais c'est aussi
la fusion avec la culture créole il ya
beaucoup de similitudes beaucoup de
liens de parenté entre certains rythmes
latino-américains et le maloya par
exemple et puis et puis bien entendu on
pense tout naturellement à la capoeira
brésilienne au moringue
et tout ça ça va être présenté donc ça
va être très festif ça va être une belle
fusion
voilà alors il ya plein de danse connu
bien sûr mon la salsa oui mais des
choses qu'on ne connaît pas malade et
des noms je dire mais qu'est ce que
c'est
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme dans ce vin
dans socom d'un fils musicaux alors je
vais vous parler de la chacarera voilà
ça vient d'où ça vient d'argentine
je vais vous parler du wine audusseau
juanito du rôle aux pauvres des yeux
lien par exemple des danses chilienne
phare des musiques et des danses 6 1 qui
sont joués on va dire en live par des
par le groupe tropicale andino notamment
composée de chiliens entre autres je
vais vous parler du merengue de saint
domingue la cumbia la cumbia cessé de
colombie on la trouve aussi dans
certains pays d ordre on la trouve au
chili et au mexique d'ailleurs aussi on
devra tous ces styles au festi latino et
il ya aussi les styles brésilien alors
on connaît on connaît le sens baky qui
est bravo le symbole
et oui et puis et puis tous les styles
qui en découle le samba reggae de
salvador le samba funk qui a qui est une
fusion intéressante et qui sera joué
avec le groupe arco iris
alors en attendant espagnol on va
entendre donc du portugais alors on
dansera bien sûr on en sera d'autant
plus qu' à des initiations des cours de
danse l'après midi une heure de tango en
initiation de bachata qui vient de saint
domingue à l'origine et puis de samba
brésilienne
voilà et ensuite ça on va dire ça mais
en quelque sorte un petit peu
l'échauffement pouvoir danser au moment
des concerts qui commence à 18h alors
donc arco iris quintet brésilien
tropicale latino ils sont donc à leur
mélange et chili avec le bassiste qui
est qui et créole qui est très
talentueux et puis voilà c'est un
mélange vous avez suivi ensuite chine
suivie c'est très bien c'est parce que
c'est un style afro péruviens
c'est ce style là s'appelle festejo et
le landau et quand on écoute les
premières mesures de ce style là on se
dit que c'est du maloya
c'est vraiment très très étonnant et
puis ensuite on reconnaît quelque chose
d'un peu différent dès que la guitare
entrer que le ch en espagnol se met se
met à intervenir
et là on se dit mais c'est une rythmique
ternaire de type maloya avec des accents
qui sont un petit peu différent mais
c'est très très proches
et ça j'avais envie de le montrer et du
coup le groupe steam qui vivent à
réaliser une fusion des morceaux en
commun avec kalba sa mère qui est du
maloya traditionnel et puis y'a pas de
retenir pas de porter le pianiste bien
renommée à la réunion issus du jazz est
qui qui est très très on va dire
talentueux dans les musiques latinos que
ce soit brésilienne ou afro cubaine et
là il fera l'ouverture du festival en
solo avec une danse argentine
qui se terminera par une justement dans
chaque année là qui sera jouée au piano
par par pat ça ça va être grandiose
qu'on adore l'année prochaine bon je
pense que vous êtes déjà en train de
concocter la quatrième édition mais il
ya déjà des propositions et mais dans la
programmation je tenais vraiment à
parler aussi du groupe à tous qu'il ya
je suis la voix là bas tous qu'il est à
son âge que c'est le cada moi je connais
batucada alors c'est le nombre à tous
qu'il ya vient de la batucada donc la
petite batucadas et une bateau qui n'y
est la batucada de l'île de la réunion
c'est le bateau qu'il y a bon voilà bon
c'est un petit jeu comme ça de mots
c'est l'instant on n'a pas prévu mais
vous dire mais je suis ouvert à toutes
ces propositions là mais le groupe à
tous qu'il ya ce sont des jeunes et ça
je tenais aussi à ce que ça fasse partie
fessiers latino des jeunes issus d'un
établissement médico-social de l'alefpa
céline pro marie-caze et qui ont monté
un atelier percussions brésiliennes avec
enfin avec le personnel éducatif et ils
ont non seulement je dirais des
compétences mais aussi des réels talents
suffisamment en tout cas pour pouvoir
monter sur scène avec avec tout le monde
quoi donc festi latino festival sans
alcool festival autour de de l'amérique
latine toutes ces cultures et puis qui
permet l'accès à la scène pour tous
voilà tous les talents sont représentés
aussi bien les personnes en situation de
handicap que les artistes pro et en plus
les prix sont abordables 5 vous crevez
au fait baisser les enchères c'est bien
moi je vous dis bravo
l'accès à la culture pour tous on essaie
de s'y tenir alors effectivement on a on
a peu de moyens enfin on essaie de faire
vivre
cet événement là et puis on espère que
ça se pérennisera et que quand on aura
des moyens de plus en plus importants
pour pouvoir accueillir d'autres voilà
d'autres spécialités et puis voilà vous
demander des subventions
on en a eu on en a eu la région
notamment
et puis le reste sont des actions de
reconnaît récolte de fonds quoi des
pique niques participatif des collectes
des cagnottes sur leetchi.com qui sont
encore en cours donc n'hésitez pas
pourquoi vous n'avez pas joué à la
médiathèque de saint-pierre peut-être
que ça vous en contera du monde
eh bien allez je lance à les séjours
vous allez là-bas même gratos mais vous
allez au moins vous amener un gros parce
que on découvre le monde le monde latino
réunion bêtement alors cesser ces gens
dont créer cette communauté la dame est
relative elle vit principalement dans le
sud d'envoi ce trou ou là un peu partout
seront disséminés un peu partout et on a
souvent l'occasion des ronds n'a souvent
l'occasion les rencontrer à l'occasion
de pique nique fameux pique nique latino
qui sont organisés depuis une douzaine
quinzaine d'années et qui prennent de
l'ampleur à chekhov un peu à huy des
cours à oui j'ai été voir la prochaine
date un américain bien sûr avec plaisir
avec plaisir et ça prend de l'ampleur
parce que effectivement c'est pas c'est
pas fermé on accueille tout le monde
effectivement tous ceux qui ont envie de
découvrir toutes ces cultures là et
c'est l'occasion pour tous les latinos
d'amener des spécialités culinaires de
leur pays quoi donc le ceviche chilien
les emprunts nadas les tortillas les
tacos les bullet hausse voilà on
découvre tout ça aussi quoi mais ça se
seront fait style attiser alors je vous
dis bravo parce que franchement ça me
donne envie de venir et je connaissais
absolument pas ce festival je découvre
dans ça se passe en rappel donc à au
musée stella matutina un haut lieu de la
culture réunionnaise danser c'est très
bien que ce soit associé à ça c'est le
samedi 9 juillet pour entrer tout le
monde à l'intérieur la suite les gens
qui vont venir
on organise en extérieur justement sur
les ondes d'accord oui voilà on l'a on
organise une scène un podium
inférieure et puis les stands sont tout
aussi mon histoire de gastronomie avec
je disais torti mec cl bistrot latine
obtenu par nicolas rada chilien qui est
chef cuistot en même temps que musicien
artiste
alors donc on rappelle sans alcool sans
alcool voilà rapidement
voilà c'est pas répressif on n'interdit
rien n'y aura pas de dalle côté sale
entrez simplement on ne vend pas sur
place d'alcool et puis on espère que
tout le monde jouera le jeu et on entre
par des bouteilles d'alcool
bien sûr que non ce sera autre chose car
ainsi un centre des cas des malades est
revenu il est donc je peux vous donne
quelques petites informations avant que
nous terminons cette démission pour
détruire tout d'abord donné papier ça y
est alors pour terminer je vous signale
la pièce ubu roi et moi et moi avec jean
laurent faubourg et david erudel et
virginie bénard ça se passe le 2 juin
aux cases du dos d'âne à 18 heures et le
6 juin à la médiathèque pendant que je
pense que oui le 6 juin la médiathèque
de la chaloupe saint leu à 15 heures
dans un instant elodie après france info
tu cette émission je vous le rappelle
est à réécouter sur notre site en
podcast allez n'oubliez pas donc fait
style latino et l'écran pendant
médiathèque la semaine prochaine à saint
pierre merci d'être venus bonne soirée
et à la semaine prochaine
et n'oubliez pas demain c'est le sakifo
music nous serons présents